[Music]
why hello dc phantom welcome to the kent
home well if you'd like to come in just
wipe off your shoes first it's dusty out
there
hey everyone so we're just going to take
you on a brief tour of the house this is
a staircase that is i want to say it's a
fake staircase but it's not it it just
doesn't go to anything it's like right
beyond up there the great beyond that is
right so this is our hallway
um as you can see you got some family
photos and some other stuff and we shoot
i would say the majority of our scenes
are in the kitchen a non-working fridge
with actually look at that nothing in it
tyler has a drawer in this kitchen that
he hides his stuff in
i also have a door in this kitchen that
i hide my stuff in
and i have
a candy stash i have a note saying bitsy
stuff please leave in the drawer more
candy hand sanitizer eye drops water
sides hair things my phone it's like a
freshman locker yeah
[Laughter]
let's go into what was formerly martha
kent's bedroom but is now lois's office
personally this is my favorite room in
the house i think it has just the
coolest amount of stuff around there's a
really cute family photo over here if i
had to pick something that i wanted to
take home from set other than my candy
in my candy drawer it would be this
photo one thing i would take home is
this little old camera it's old brown
camera it's really cool i'm always
constantly fidgeting with it and having
to memorize exactly where it was so that
i don't ruin everything
dining room scenes i would say we shoot
most of our eating scenes in the kitchen
we've had some stuff in here out the
window i remember when i first started
shooting on graham i was like oh so cool
there's these crazy
large photographs that get changed
according to time of day the exterior of
the farmhouse is totally separate and we
shoot all the exterior scenes there
anything interior is on our stages
we also shoot a lot in the living room
this was one of my favorite scenes which
was uh the big paint fight yes yeah yeah
that was really fun
so uh sometimes during lunch i come here
and i play piano to unwind a lot of the
crew kind of joins in and whatnot and
people start singing along so you know a
lot of people have fun in this uh little
room when we're not exactly working as
well
you know
it's fun
my talented son
the boys bedrooms are on another stage
so
because again the upstairs is is to the
great beyond and then there's a porch
that wraps around but we typically shoot
the porch scenes outside on the exterior
farmhouse set
thank you everyone for joining us on
this tour of the kent house we hope you
join us for the rest of season two and
the beyond
and uh thanks for watching
[Music]
you